first of all right off the bat how are
y'all doing how are you feeling today
and how are you doing I'm doing I'm
doing well thank God families well
friends well thank goodness and today
I'm very happy we've been it's been very
happy because we've been able to talk
about the heaviness that's going on in
our nation so yeah overwhelmed but
feeling feeling grateful I'm ready for
change
yeah and you know we're doing the top
from our homes that's why it's the talk
at home and Eve you're in London yeah
I'm in London John it so yeah it's been
this that's incredible yeah yeah yeah I
think I when you asked how I'm feeling
pandemic arise you know I understand
what needs to be done now when you're
talking about rebellion wise I feel a
lot of hope but I wish it didn't happen
for this to occur you don't a man coming
right it didn't take this yes and didn't
have to lose another man had to lose his
life yeah another person had to lose
their life for the world to wake up
either I find it interesting though that
we see in Berlin in London's samplers in
the pop Liga up their jerseys every at
Ernie Strickland I was amazed when I saw
the video down by Parliament what does
that been like for you to see that
response it's a beautiful beautiful
feeling I am so overwhelmed by all of it
but to see those crowds and it's not
just like 20 people not just like a
hundred people there are thousands of
people coming out in different countries
marching down to the American Embassy
here in London is in Trafalgar Square it
is it's a beautiful thing this is a
global problem we are again in this
together we were saying that like you
said sure about the pandemic we are
again in this together that's right yeah
that's right
sure you guys go and you address
everything on the talk how is that calm
sation because you're amongst friends
but there are a lot of people listening
to your friendly conversation we have
interesting conversations where were
among our ears and I know how
comfortable you all feel together yes
how do you handle that conversation
knowing it's being broadcast you know I
think it's a great conversation is very
comfortable conversation because we are
so close we are friends we are truly
friends in real life so we talk as if we
friends we talk as if we're on a kitchen
table you know that we're all together
even though we're in separate homes
that's how we're talking to each other
what I love about this is the dialogue
is healthy look at what's going on where
you have police marching with peaceful
protesters when you have a chain of
white women circling people to protect
people when you have black men
protecting police officers you know so
there is a change coming even in the
entertainment industry when you see
Jamie Foxx and Michael Jordan Michael B
Jordan but you also are seeing John
Stamos and Richard Marx and you seeing
Jane Fonda and Billy Eilish and pink you
seeing these people understand that we
have got to battle racism this is a
conversation that has to be bad for our
country to move on to its greatness
last year Hollywood led the way with the
conversation on sexism and and now will
Hollywood lead the way with this
conversation about racism and is the
world ready for changing what kind of
platform should celebrities like y'all
be on are used to help change I think
we're I think we're so lucky that we are
already on such an amazing platform to
be on the top to have the eyes that are
on us to be on this network that eyes
are on the network for them to also we
saw email today that went around that
they are in support of you know black
community and black creators and black
lives and and in support of trying to
figure out what the solution is they
want to figure out what the solution is
going to be
I think it's our responsibility all of
our responsibility who have any sort of
light in any way and I mean that in the
sense of being in the public eye there
is no time to be quiet there is no time
to now to just sit back everyone has a
responsibility a responsibility to say
something to their their people their
universe and that to me that you know
reverberates out out out out out so I we
can't be quiet
we just piggyback on what you're saying
eat when it comes from the time when it
comes from George cheeks at the top when
you hear Marva smalls you talk about
global Viacom CBS Bob package you know
it doesn't get any bigger than that when
we feel here on the top and everybody
throughout the network feels empowered
to use this platform we're not just
trying to entertain we're trying to
empower and educate we don't want you to
be allies we want you to be our brothers
and sisters in the struggle so much so
that even you see the music industry get
minutes mm-hmm music industry comfort
for a black out tomorrow what do you
think of that I think it's incredible I
think it's incredible I think like I
said everyone is using their platform
everybody is using what they can their
mediums to figure to do what they can do
to help this look this is it's just I
have never seen anything like this ever
and wow I am so overwhelmed and it is
sickening I watch the news and I'm doing
to it like everyone else
I love seeing those peaceful protests I
loved seeing those different colors
those different genders all together
with one arm one fist in the air on one
on one knee I do think you know while
there's this heart of the harbor riots
and those people there are some people
out there taking advantage of the
situation there are millions more who
really want to find a solution who by
the way we and we talked about this
earlier share alike listen okay it's not
gonna be easy but we all have to be
comfortable with the
idea of being uncomfortable these
conversations are going to be
uncomfortable and it's gonna take a lot
to find a solution but I do think that
there are millions and millions of
people who are willing to do it who are
ready to do it and and and everybody
plays their part when dr. King said that
the riot is the language of the unheard
well now we can all use our voices we
can all use our platforms to really make
sure people are heard and change occurs
but the biggest thing about this we knew
what we need to do for the pandemic we
knew we need to wear masks we knew we
need to stay home hashtag alone together
now we need to let everybody know what
you must do to battle racism yeah and in
our country and I love the fact that
everybody's coming on board if you
convince somebody to do it text on video
can I convince you to fill out your
census form can I convince you to
register to vote
can I in advance you to become a part of
the solution look at these police chiefs
these governors and everybody in
entertainment from country-western
singers rock singers everybody has come
together said this will not stand
because the media saw the videotape of
the murder of George flood Floyd when
Kevin Fraser I want to say to you as a
black man as a black man you are
representing us very well and I even
fear for you if you gotta run an errand
you know me listen it is it is a it has
been a precarious time for a while and
people's eyes are finally opening up I
mean this is something you know today is
the anniversary of the Tulsa massacre
and people don't realize that and they
forget that a whole city was wiped out
they were bombing people
oh there's been a state of terrorism for
quite some time so it's important now
that we all rise up and kind of link
arms together